la vie loin d'être rose à winnipeg en
le coût de la vie est élevé l'inflation
galopante et le chômage généralisé des
milliers de soldats rentrent au pays et
ne trouvent pas d'emploi
les conditions de travail sont
exécrables le 15 mai 1919 à 7 heures du
matin trente mille employés se mettent
en grève
ce mouvement touche tous les secteurs
d'activités publiques comme privées des
hôtels aux usines en passant par les
petits commerces de détail
les policiers les pompiers ou encore les
téléphonistes c'est une ville lui
relations de travail sont extrêmement
durs lorsque la guerre éclate en 1919
donc à la fois on a un patronat winnipeg
qui est qui particulièrement dre hostile
dans ses rapports avec le mouvement
ouvrier avec les travailleurs les
revendications des employés de la
métallurgie et de la construction à
l'origine de la grève initiales sont des
hausses de salaires à vincennes de leurs
une semaine de travail à 44 eur et le
droit de négociation collective pour les
syndicats les tentatives de négociations
échouent et la tension monte des
grévistes sont arrêtés et emprisonnés la
violence culmine le 21 juin c'est le
samedi sanglant
ce jour là des milliers de winnipeg oies
se rassemblent sur l'art humaine
malgré l'interdiction de manifester les
forces de l'ordre chargent la foule des
coups de feu sont tirés faisant un mort
et plusieurs blessés des gens se sauve
dans ce qu'on appelait l aller et puis
là on les suit et puis on le donne des
coups de bâton sa tête et il ya
plusieurs centaines de personnes qui
sont blessées
après six semaines d'agitation la grève
se termine il ouvriers notre scénario de
ce qu'il demande en vain leur demande
était plutôt modéré le désordre des
améliorations salariales
la reconnaissance du droit de négocier
collectivement la garantie que tous les
ouvriers en grève pourrait retrouver
leur emploi dont ils ont ils obtiennent
rien de tout ça malgré cette défaite
cuisante
la grève reste tout de même un moment
pivot dans l'histoire canadienne
plusieurs leaders grévistes se lance en
politique et se font élire alors même
qu'ils sont en prison
ce qu'on a gagné si l'activisme
politique des gens puissent se sont
rendu compte qu'on avait besoin de
policiers qui partagent nos valeurs
petit à petit ces anciens syndicalistes
entrée en politique influence la vie
canadienne et notamment les lois du
travail à la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale par exemple le premier ministre
mackenzie king reconnaît le droit de
négociation collective réclamé en 1919
mis en place les règles encadrant le
travail la loi sur les relations de
travail la sécurité au travail
bref de nombreuses régulations qu'on
tient pour acquise aujourd'hui trouvent
leur origine dans cette grève de 1919 et
[Musique]
un tel événement aurait peu de chances
de se reproduire aujourd'hui
de l'aveu même du syndicaliste mais
prévient-il
la frustration des gens peut conduire à
des actions radicales
ici thibault jourdan radio canada à
winnipeg
[Musique]